this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
your paranasal sinuses are air-filled
spaces in the bones around your nose
they are connected to the inside of your
nose through small passageways
a thin layer of tissue called nasal
mucosa lines the inside of your nose and
your sinuses
this tissue makes a thick and slippery
fluid called mucus
mucus keeps your nose from drying out
moistens the air you breathe
and protects against germs dust and
pollen
when your sinuses are healthy mucus can
drain freely out of your nose
sometimes your mucosa may become swollen
and inflamed causing your sinuses to be
blocked
the blockage can trap mucus inside your
sinuses
if this condition lasts more than three
months it's called chronic sinusitis
if medication or other treatments aren't
helping your healthcare provider may
advise you to have surgery
endoscopic sinus surgery is the most
common procedure for chronic sinusitis
to start the surgeon will insert a
camera on the end of a thin tool called
an endoscope into your nose
images from the camera will be sent to a
video screen so that your surgeon can
see the inside of your nose
then your surgeon will look for and
remove anything that blocks the opening
to your sinuses
this will allow mucus to drain from your
sinuses and improve airflow after the
procedure you may have nasal bandages
for a few days
your healthcare provider will ask you to
use a saline rinse to help you recover
talk to your healthcare provider to find
out more about endoscopic sinus surgery